es el momento de hablar de las noticias
de la economía con mi compañera Daniela
hablando Daniela Buen día para usted
Hola Muy buenos días Ángela pues las
noticias comienzan con los precios del
petróleo que amanecieron disparados
Daniela si Ángela pues las dos
referencias más utilizadas en el mundo
que son el frente de Europa y el wt y
del Golfo de México amanecieron con
alzas de casi 7 por ciento Esta es la
mayor alza en casi un año y sobrepasan
los 80 dólares por barril la ópera más
es el grupo de exportadores y sus
aliados liderados por Rusia que surten
alrededor del 40% de la demanda mundial
de crudo y sus miembros se reúnen hoy
sin embargo algunos de ellos ya
sacudieron al mercado al anticipar el
domingo nuevo su recortes en sus
objetivos de producción de alrededor de
un poco más de un millón de barriles por
día a partir de mayo se trata de Arabia
Saudita por ejemplo que dijo que lo
harán 500.000 barriles diarios y varias
otras naciones hicieron lo mismo
Irak emiratos árabes Unidos entre otros
Pero por qué lo hicieron acá la
hipótesis de un analista
lo que decía él es que es que
básicamente los mercados Están
preocupados por la crisis financiera o
la crisis bancaria que se comenzó con la
quiebra del silicon y también por los
temores sobre que china no pueda
recuperarse tan rápido como esperaba de
todas maneras
Ángel Hazte anunció también le da
combustible al Dólar ya que mayores
precios del petróleo llevan a más
inflación y a su vez hace que los bancos
centrales tengan que subir seguir
subiendo sus tasas de interés Daniel en
otros temas de Twitter comenzó a
eliminar las etiquetas de verificación
de los medios de comunicación y este es
un nuevo Twitter muy caótico que no a
todo el mundo le gusta no Claro Ángela y
es que la empresa del multimillonario
elon mosca había dado el sábado como
último plazo para que los usuarios
comenzaran a pagar una mesa una
membresía mensual eso para mantener su
famosa insignia azul pero hubo Quienes
se opusieron como de New York Times que
ahora aparece sin este sello de
verificación como observamos en la
imagen y es que esta una de las
organizaciones de noticias más
despreciadas del Magnate de los autos de
lujo de Times dijo en una historia el
jueves que no pagaría Twitter por la
verificación de sus cuentas
institucionales y eso le valió una serie
de respuestas despectivas por parte del
dueño de la red social entre ellas que
este periódico es imposible de leer dice
él esta de todas maneras de New York
Times ha informado ampliamente sobre las
fallas en los sistemas de conducción
parcialmente
automatizados en tesla a la compañía de
automóviles eléctricos de la que también
es dueño de elon musk y también hay
otros medios de comunicación Como de
associates que también han dicho que no
pagarán las marcas de verificación que
varían entre 8 dólares por mes para los
usuarios individuales y hasta mil
dólares mensuales para las
organizaciones Como por ejemplo de New
York Times pues mucha confusión porque
las voces de autoridad ya no van a tener
la marca azul que los distingue y en
cambio sí Muchos Bots o cuentas que no
sabemos qué contenido traen y pagan por
este
bueno por ese azul Daniela en otros
temas en Australia hay una empresa que
logró obtener una albóndiga de mamut a
partir de sus células cuéntenos Ángela
se trata de la startup que es una de las
más de 100 empresas de todo el mundo que
están trabajando en productos cárnicos
cultivados es decir hechos en
laboratorios a partir de células
animales y que hizo carne de mamut un
mamífero extinto hace mucho tiempo pero
la hizo a partir de células extraídas de
un pariente cercano un elefante en
África con Esta técnica no es necesario
sacrificar el animal para producirlo
Pero eso no quiere decir que mamut va a
aterrizar en los platos de todo el mundo
en el corto plazo hasta ahora Singapur
es el único país que ha aprobado el
consumo de carne a base de células
queríamos entusiasmar a la gente con el
hecho de que el futuro de la comida sea
diferente a lo que tenemos que hay cosas
que son únicas y mejores que las carnes
que estamos comiendo ahora ahora sabemos
que murió a causa del cambio climático
entonces lo que queríamos hacer era ver
si podíamos crear algo un símbolo de un
futuro más prometedor no solo mejor para
nosotros sino también para el planeta
bueno parece muy innovador pero no está
exento de polémica Ángela por ejemplo el
gobierno italiano presentó un proyecto
de ley para prohibir esta clase de
alimentos producidos en laboratorios yo
me conservo En mi opinión por el momento
Daniela pero le agradezco a usted y más
adelante nos vemos con más noticias Así
es Ángela
[Música]